hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich mache heute ein
türkisches rezept und zwar gibt es
türkische apfeltaschen und die sind wie
die deutschen apfeltaschen jetzt aus so
einem blätterteig sondern dass er so
eine website mit backpulver allerdings
denn die gehen auch noch ein bisschen
auf und heute habe ich mir auch eine
richtig schöne form ausgedacht bzw
die form gibt es schon ich hab sie mir
nicht ausgedacht sondern ich mache
einfach nach und ich zeige ich jetzt
einfach mal kurz die zutaten für den
teig und später zeigt sich die zutaten
für die füllung
ich brauche einen 100 gramm zucker ich
nehme etwas vanille extrakt und eine
prise salz
ich habe 400 gramm joghurt da nehme ich
so einen 35 prozentigen also keinen
stich westen also der stadt trotzdem
stichfest aber nicht so ein
hochprozentiger als zehnprozentige dann
habe ich 100 milliliter öl dann nehme
ich jetzt ein maiskeimöl könnte aber
auch ein sonnenblumenöl benutzen
hauptsache neutral 500 gramm mehl und
ein päckchen backpulver das war es auch
schon alles was du zu hause hat normal
eigentlich alles was der heimat um äpfel
habe ich auch mal deswegen kann ich die
apfeltaschen eigentlich immer machen
jetzt geht es zuerst das ei in die
rührschüssel da kommt zucker mit rein
vanille extrakten paar tropfen
ich finde das passt jemand ganz gut in
der 3 ich glaube du warst immer reicher
macht ja auch normal immer vanillezucker
rein und vanille extrakt schaut
intensiver und schmeckt besser und ich
hatte echte vanille und keine künstliche
denn die prise salz und dann las ich das
einfach mal ganz kurz verrühren
und wenn sie das anstellen verbunden hat
gebe ich jetzt noch joghurt und öl mit
und lasst es auch kurz verrühren
und jetzt gebe ich nur so viel mehl mit
rein bis es ein schöner glatter teig ich
zwischendurch auch mal das backpulver
mit dazu
und da nur so viel benutzten dieses
ebenen festtag ist es kommt darauf an
wie groß auch das ei ist also der
kanzlei sein dass er dann 50 gramm
weniger mehl braucht müsste einfach
beobachten
am besten dann auch einfach mal rein
fassen und wenn er noch sehr weich ist
noch bisschen mehr eingehen weil wir
müssen den tag später aufholen können
und das restliche mehl gebe ich jetzt
hier auch die arbeitsfläche habe ich nur
noch ein bisschen also bei mir ich
brauche heute wirklich die kompletten
500 gramm mehl dann gebe ich da den teig
drauf und das knete ich jetzt noch kurz
mit der hand ein
da hab da einfach ein besseres gefühl
auch für den teig wissmann dazu trocken
wird wandern noch zu feucht wird weil
wir arbeiten ja gleich mit den händen
weiter
und dann sollte einfach so ein teig
entstehen der nicht mehr an den fingern
klebt also wenn man so mit dem finger
auch mal reingeht dafür nicht mehr
kleben das bislang brauche ich jetzt
doch nicht mehr
jetzt lasse ich den teig erstmal
ausruhen geben ihn dafür hier in eine
schüssel mach hier kurz sauber und dann
bereite ich in der zeit nämlich schon
mal die füllung vor ich habe jetzt die
zutaten für die füllung gerichtet ich
mach das halt mit äpfeln weil es absolut
tasche sind aber ihr könnt natürlich
auch nach saison zum beispiel birnen
benutzen mit was anderem habe ich
eigentlich noch nie gefühlt weil er
absolut taschen
naja körpern so also ich brauche für die
füllung drei äpfel
ich habe zweimal pink lady und ein
granny smith ihr könnt auch andere äpfel
benutzen
der schall schön säuberlich die zwei
sind so süß säuerlich also müsste
einfach mal gucken wie es dann
geschmacklich fast dann habe ich hier
zwei esslöffel zucker weil ich glaube
ich muss ein bisschen nach süßen ein
teelöffel zimt vielleicht nämlich auch
mittelmeer und damit ich noch ein
bisschen bis mit drin hab nämlich 100
gramm walnüsse die hab ich aber gleich
kommen wissen nehm ich mir zuerst und
entkernen die ihnen einmal einmal
durchbohren
was ist heutzutage alles gibt
durchgeschnitten und das team rausgeholt
arbeitserleichterung vor allem stress
halt cool wenn es ein absolut keine hast
wenn du mal bratapfel macht im winter
dann kann schon immer schnell füllen
weiter hat in der mitte das loch also
man beim ihrer familie essen mit fleisch
komplett ganz also mit allem drum und
dran
jack ahnt ja auch wenn der bauch kann
wir mit dem bau noch mit ballaststoffen
was weiß ich weiß ja wenn mir ein
smoothie machen schweiz sich auch mal
ausgetragen aber jetzt in der abwehr
tasche möchte ich das nicht mit
deswegen kann ich ganz gern aufheben und
kannst dance musik habe ich meine
special effekt machen die man ab leer
jawohl mein kamera special effekt kann
man ja wohl
das ist ein schlüsselloch perspektive
gesehen
ich habe immer besser ich werde ich
verschwand ich bin ja steven spielberg
der bankbranche es ein schlechtes
gewissen gemacht jetzt schädigen apfel
aufnimmt ich nehme ich dann viertel ich
ihn einmal und muss ihnen durch
schreiben dass nach ich jetzt gleich hin
der kenwood ihr könnt aber auch mit ganz
normalen küchen reibe benutzen ich
glaube doch kleinkriegen gemacht weil
sonst das alles ist hier auf ich weiß
ihr später in den sphären kriegst du ich
mach dir nur den sterblichkeit erste hat
man durch schreiben
gebe ich das schon einmal in meinem
pfanne wenn es natürlich auch die
kenwood habt könnt ihr das natürlich
auch in der kern wird kochen
aber ich möchte dass man das jetzt auch
gut seht ihr das gut rein schauen könnt
und nicht jeder hat deswegen mache ich
das ganz normal in der pfanne oder in
einem topf könnte hier auch direkt in
zucker mit rein geben
und den 10
ob ich nicht ein bisschen mehr als ein
teelöffel ihres geschmacks und jetzt
gebe ich hier in den mixer auch das nix
messer rein und hacken die wahl müsse
klein
die kommen auch gleich mitnehmen stefan
mandel oder rasen ist oder irgendwas
anderes nehmen oder ihr lasst sie hat
einfach weg
mit kleiner die jetzt auch nicht
komplett sondern lasse etwas stickig und
geführt die jetzt aber dazu kommen koche
ich erstmal die äpfel auf und kocht die
so lange bis die flüssigkeit dann
verdunstet ich also erzähl dir die äpfel
sind noch relativ fest aber die lassen
gleich die flüssigkeit raus und wenn die
verdunstete standen die sind fertig mit
dem kochvorgang
natürlich diese apfel masse um damit sie
schneller abkühlt deswegen in so einem
großen flachen teller oder eine große
flache schale dann kann man sie nämlich
gleich weiter benutzen
und ich finde hier fehlt noch ein aroma
und zwar ist das zitronenschale und das
ist eine bio zitrone können wir die
schale schön verwenden um mit rein
reiben sich meine kleine schreibe gerade
in der spülmaschine nämlich die große
arbeit haben hält aber die große
zitronen stücke mit drin
doch mal von früher und dann könnt ihr
da ist sagte wales im trend
und ich breite so ein bisschen aus damit
einfach schneller abkühlt und während
die masse jetzt abkühlt kann ich schon
mal den teig vorbereiten und den
indikationen ein teil und das mache ich
jetzt hier auf meiner holz arbeitsfläche
war ich da einfach schöne ausruhen
den teig nehme ich jetzt hier einmal
raus gewählt die arbeitsfläche auch ein
bisschen zu viel mehr klebt der weg sagt
dazu dann friedlich ihn
und rollt die einzelnen teile jetzt zu
einem ball
ich habe den teig jetzt auch in fünf
portionen eingeteilt weil er sonst so
groß wird also die einzelnen stücke also
tennisball groß ist die richtige größe
ich glaube ich habe zwar noch nie ein
tennisball hinterhand aber martin ist
groß die sportskanone und jetzt rolle
ich das schön rund aussteller groß in
etwa das sind so ungefähr 20 cm im
durchmesser
ganz ehrlich was zu machen würde ich
aber jetzt weiß ich was ich kenne diese
dinge die sie gerade richtig lecker zu
töten
und ich hab dir mal mit birnen gemacht
mit apfel ich halte zwar zu einer ganz
normale form jetzt hab ich halt noch
eine schöne form entdeckt dass krieg
nicht cool jetzt nämlich ein messer und
teile den teig durch vier als einmal
durch viertel wie so ein kuchen und dann
nehmt ihr das messer und schneidet so v
förmig ein nur darf sich das gehalt
nicht berühren also hier einmal also
nicht berührt ich ganz viel nicht
berühren also die spitze da vorne muss
noch zusammen bleiben das ganze zwei mal
dachten wir nicht berührt genau da ist
sie noch zu teils verbunden
und dann setzen wir jetzt hier mit ich
die füllung rein deswegen ist auch
wichtig dass die füllung also dass diese
flüssigkeit wirklich komplett weg ist
ansonsten tritt es hier nämlich alles
aus was ich hier einmal mit ich rein so
1 bis eineinhalb teelöffel voll könnte
auch mit den schülern bisschen
nachhelfen
und dann werden die zwei seiten einmal
umgekehrt
so einmal rechts einmal links und dann
nehmt ihr euch das messer und schneidet
unten noch schön weg damit schön gerade
wird außerdem müsste das hier bisserl zu
drücken und dann haben wir eine schöne
form die sätze ich jetzt hier auf ein
backblech und macht es mit dem
restlichen teig genauso
ich habe jetzt hier zwölf stück auf dem
blech liegen im mittel platz dazwischen
lassen denn die gehen ja noch auf ich
habe ein päckchen backpulver mit drin
und so werden die jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei opern 1370 180 grad für
etwa 15 mit 20 minuten backen bis die
oberfläche eben schön aber bis es so
leicht brauchen wird und dann holen was
raus lassen sie abkühlen und dann zeige
ich euch wie man sie versteht
die apfeltaschen sind jetzt schon
abgekühlt und jetzt bestreut sie mit
süßem schnee dass sich dieser extra
feine puderzucker der schmilzt anhalt
und bleibt dann auch die ganze zeit
schön drauf so gehalt auf den berlinern
bei der bäckerei und im ganzen haus
duftet wirklich nach diesen apfeltaschen
nach senden noch äpfel nehme ich die und
setzte schön auf eine platte drauf und
können das sind nämlich so servieren
nicht sagen demokratisch nämlich jetzt
schon bei der arbeit darf die karima
einfach probieren
allein schon die form so schön
kompliziert aus dabei ist ganz einfach
noch ein packen würde in so einer super
schlüssel zum beispiel und verschließt
dann wenn sie noch ein bisschen weich
wenn man möchte dass er eben schön
knusprig bleiben kann man sie ein
bisschen offen stehen lassen wobei sie
dann wieder schnell austrocknen aber ich
finde es auch richtig gut
und damit fällt halt das muster halt
richtig schön und so einfach mit ganz
wenig besorgt gemacht mit einfach mit
einem messer und wenn ihr das jetzt nach
machen wollt dürft ihr gerne auf salehs
blog.de
da gibt es noch einmal die genaue
anleitung mit den mengenangaben und
falls ihr die übrigens etwas kleiner
machen wollt müsste halt nicht nur fünf
bälle machen sondern einfach sechs oder
sieben kleine bällchen dann werden
nämlich auch die teile automaten
automatisch kleiner
wobei ich die so von der größe her ganz
gut finde aber wenn man halt zum
beispiel noch mehr anbieten möchte zum
tee und kaffee kann man ja auch gerne
diese kleider machen
jetzt würde ich ja noch viel spaß beim
nachmachen und ich schieß jetzt nochmal
foto für instagram und für facebook da
können nämlich auch mal vorbeischauen
und wir sehen uns dann ganz einfach beim
nächsten mal
bis dann